merci pour votre présence à cette heure
matinale nous avons l'objectif de
terminer cette audition à 9h55 précise
pour que madame la Première ministre
puisse rejoindre notamment le Conseil
des ministre donc n'hésitez pas à passer
le message aux collègues qui arrivent de
sorte à ce qu'il ne soi pas choqué par
cette annonce donc en premier point de
notre ordre du jour nous avons donc le
plaisir d'accueillir Madame Agnès panier
runaché ministre de la transition
énergétique pour qu'elle nous présente
un bilan des négociations lors de la 28e
conférence des partis à la convention
cadre des Nations Unies sur les
changements climatique la fameuse COP 28
merci beaucoup madame la ministre merci
de votre présence merci d'avoir accepté
de venir devant la Commission du
développement durable et l'aménagement
du territoire il me semble que regard de
votre engage ement et de la place que
vous avez joué dans ces négociations il
était logique que nous vous
auditiontionnons madame la
ministre au vu des principaux résultats
diffusés au fil de ces négociations
jusqu'à leur conclusion le 13 décembre
dernier il semble que celles-ci ont
connu des hauts et des bas pour aboutir
finalement à un accord accepté par
l'ensemble des parties nous avons pu
apprécier l'avancée dès le premier jour
notamment sur le fond perte et préjudice
suivi par le feuilleton sur la mention
des énergies fossiles qui a duré si je
ne m'abuse jusqu'au dernier jour ces
négociations ont heureuse ont
heureusement été conclusive mais ils ont
été aussi un révélateur de lign de
facture entre les États je rappelle que
l'Union européenne est allée jusqu'à
juger inacceptable à juste titre la
version proposée le 11 décembre par la
présidence
émirati après que les pays de l'OPEP
ont ont refusé tout la mise en cause des
énergies fossiles vous étiez vous-même
déclaré stupéfaite par cette initiative
la vigueur des termes employé tranche
avec le ton généralement policé des
expressions dans les instances
internationales sans doute pouvez-vous
nous livrer votre sentiment sur ce sujet
je vous laisserai bien évidemment le
soin de présenter en détail les
résultats obtenus je retiens qu'au final
l'objectif de l'accord de Paris
consistant à contenir à 1,5°gr le
réchauffement global est repris de même
que la trajectoire recommandée dans le
dernier rapport du JEC certains
objectifs précis comme le triplement de
la capacité des d'énergies renouvela
d'ici 2030 et un doublement de
l'efficacité énergétique sont assigné et
puis c'est vrai il y a eu des
formulation qui laisse parfois un
sentiment d'inachevé disons-le comme
l'objectif de s'éloigner le terme
éloigné des énergies fossiles dans les
systèmes énergétiques mais dans le même
temps l'accord ambitionne de sortir des
subventions aux énergies fossiles qui ne
répondent pas à la précarité énergétique
ou aux transitions au juste aussi vite
que possible faut-il en conclure comme
la présidente de la commission Europe
eurne Madame Van derlyen que cet accord
marque le début de l'air postfossile
c'est en tout cas un signal auquel il
faudra évidemment donner une traduction
concrète il s'agit d'une étape
importante que vous vous avez d'ailleurs
qualifié madame la ministre de victoire
de la diplomatie
diplomatique voilà climatique pardon euh
voilà madame la ministre pour ce propos
limininaire je vous laisserai le soin de
nous présenter les différents points
pour une pe petite dizaine de minutes et
puis les collègues auront l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur cet accord je vous
remercie euh merci monsieur le Président
non vous ne vous abusez pas nous avons
effectivement négocié ass siz tard dans
les différentes nuits qui se sont
succédées monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés je vous
remercie pour cette audition de votre
commission sur le bilan de la COP 28 de
Dubaï cette COP marque bien très
directement le début de l'IRE
post-fossile
8 ans après l'accord de Paris nous avons
enfin franchi cette étape importante
pour agir contre le dérèglement
climatique comme vous le savez selon le
scénario intermédiaire du GC les
politiques actuelles des pays conduisent
un réchauffement global de 2 de 2 à 2 de
8 d'ici la fin du siècle bien loin des 1
der5 de l'accord de Paris je précise
néanmoins que sans accord de Paris on
serait sur une trajectoire de 4°gr donc
on a diminué au moins d'un degré grâce à
l'accord de Paris cette trajectoire
c'est pour répondre à certains pis
vinaigres qui expliquent que les COP ça
sert à rien si ça sert à quelque chose
mais il faut aller plus loin nous sommes
encore capables d'inverser cette
tendance et je me bat chaque jour avec
cet objectif en tête mais évidemment
nous devons aller plus vite et plus fort
pour réduire nos émissions au passage
une certaine fierté à vous annoncer que
au terme de ces trois premiers
trimestres la baisse des émissions de la
France est de 4,6 % 4,6 % on se souvient
du 0,9 % en moyenne chaque année du
quinquena Hollande du 2 % du premier
quinquena Macron nous sommes sur une
trajectoire
d'accélération je pense que le dernier
trimestre sera difficile puisque nous
avons l'ffet du plan sobriété l'année
dernière et que la comparaison sera
peut-être moins favorable mais je veux
dire qu'on agit et qu'on obtient des
résultats ce que nous devons maintenant
faire c'est reéhausser les les ambitions
mondiales et c'est ce que nous avons
obtenu cet accord il est important à
plusieurs titres premier succès
important le texte contient des
engagements forts pour une transition
énergétique hors des énergies fossiles
en cohérence avec les objectifs des 1
de5 de l'accord de Paris c'est comme ça
que c'est écrit cela signifie et
l'accord le dit également que cette
sortie doit s'organiser rapidement avec
des objectifs de baisse des émissions de
43 % dès 2030 et une neutralité carbone
en 2050 donc il est faut de dire qu'il
n'y a pas d'échéance c'est la première
fois la première fois en 28 cops que
tous les pays convergent sur ce point il
s'agit d'une avancée majeure et d'un
signal très fort pour engager le monde
dans une transition sans énergie fossile
et je le dis parce que là aussi au rayon
d'épices vinaigrees certains disent que
cet accord n'a servi à rien euh ce sont
les mêmes qui ne votent pas la loi sur
les énergies renouvelables et ce sont
les mêmes qui n'ont pas un bilan
particulièrement euh positif lorsqu'ils
étaient aux manettes deuxième succès
nous avons obtenu un accord sur le
triplement des renouvelables et le
doublement de l'efficacité énergétique
c'était une priorité portée par la
France et l'Union européenne en
cohérence avec notre stratégie
énergétique que j'ai coconstruite avec
les parties prenantes et la majorité des
groupes politiques et j'ai soumise à la
consultation le 23 novembre
dernierers collèges vous aurez
l'occasion de de répondre on vous
laisser terminer la
ministre vous aurez l'occasion de
répondre allez s vous
plae non mais on met les chiffres on met
les chiffres en 2035 nous devrons
produire au ma au moins en
2035 nous devrons produire au moins 177
TWh supplémentaires d'électricité à
partir d'énergie renouvelable par
rapport à 2022 17 TWh d'électricité à
rapport à 2022 pour répondre au besoins
d'électrification et assurer notre
sécurité
d'approvisionnement nous devrons
également baisser notre consommation de
30 %. 3è succès le texte mentionne pour
la première fois la contribution
l'énergie nucléaire le mot nucléaire
apparaît dans le texte ça n'était jamais
arrivé en 28
COP tout à fait grâce à la lutte contre
le changement climatique c'est une
victoire diplomatique de la France car
très clairement nous avons porté cette
avancée avec les membres de l'Alliance
pour le nucléaire que j'ai créé en début
d'année et là les 196 pays ont montré de
manière pragmatique qui n'avait pas le
nucléaire
honteux le nucléaire c'est une énergie
je le redis d'avenir stable compétitive
et décarbonnée sur laquelle la France
continuera de miser grâce à la
prolongation des centrales existantes et
au programme nouveau nucléaire que le
Président de la République a initié lors
du discours de
Belfort concernant la France je porterai
l'année prochaine un projet de loi rel à
la souveraineté énergétique de la France
qui permettra de remettre notre pays sur
la bonne trajectoire énergétique en
s'appuyant sur un mix énergétique des
carboné avec deux piliers les énergies
renouvelables et les énergies nucléaires
4è succès l'accord final s'appuie sur la
science en reprenant les messages les
plus importants des scientifiques du GC
pour tenir la trajectoire des 1 de5 je
rappelle que l'accord de Paris c'est
pardon le faire en anglais mais c'est
comme ça qu'il est écrit below two
degree far below two degree and ping
là les références dans le texte il y en
a plus de 10 c'est 1 der5 ça veut dire
que les États y compris des États qui
sont perçus extérieurement comme peu
ambitieux d'un point de vue climatique
on peut penser par par exemple aux États
du golf ont affirmé de manière très
forte leur souhait contiennent cette
trajectoire des 1 der5 donc ça peut
paraître symbolique mais c'est en fait
un engagement assez fort
d'un point de vue multilatéral de
l'ensemble des États qui ont un rôle en
plus à jouer puisqueun état qui éimé
0,01 % d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre et qui n'a pas de fossile est un
état qui a un peu moins d'impact sur
l'ensemble de la copie cela comprend la
nécessité d'atteindre un pic de nos
émissions d'ici 2025 ça n'était pas
formulé dans les autres accords donc de
baisser nos émissions de 43 % d'ici 2030
et de 60 % d'ici 2035 là aussi ce
n'était pas des rédactions que nous
avions dans les précédents accords cet
engagement vous le savez la France et
l'Union européenne le relève en ayant
inscrit la baisse de nos émissions d'ici
2030 de 55 % dans le paquet fit for55 5e
succès cet accord reprend le travail du
pacte de Paris pour les peuples et la
planète initié par le Président de la
République notamment sur les
financements innovants là encore je le
dis ce ce sommet de Paris qui a eu lieu
en juin a eu un rôle essentiel pour
recréer de la confiance avec les pays du
Sud et pour sortir d'un face- à-face
assez peu constructif entre pays du Nord
et pays du Sud et cette façon de revoir
en profondeur la finance climatique non
pas en disant c'est les pays qui ont du
Sud qui doivent être financés par les
pays du Nord mais nous devons revoir en
profondeur le logiciel de la finance du
développement et de la finance
climatique et aller chercher d'autres
sources de financement réformer la
Banque mondiale réformer le FMI réformer
les banques multilatérales de
développement mettre en place des
taxations internationales et
trouver des
euh modalités de régulation des dettes
internationales lorsque des pays font
des investissements dans la nature c'est
le président de la République qui l'a
porté et ça a été repris ensuite dans un
certain nombre d'agendas notamment celui
de de Nairobi et dans l'initiative de de
Bridgestone la France continuera à
travailler pour faire de cette cet
agenda une réalité sur le terrain et
pour contribuer à augmenter les moyens
de mise en œuvre de la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique dans les pays
vulnérables sur tous ces points c'est la
reprise de la stratégie française et
européenne qui se retrouve dans dans un
accord endossé à 196 pays alors il y a
des marges de progrès vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le le Président nous aurions
évidemment souhaité que le texte prenne
des engagements plus forts sur le
charbon pour le moment il se contente de
copier-coller les écritures de de
Glasgow et en particulier sur la
construction de nouvelle centrale à à
charbon le texte aurait pu aussi fixer
une cible sur les émissions de méthane
dès 2030 mais nous continuerons à porter
ces positions dans de prochaines
négociation internationales et nous
avons obtenu des résultats au niveau
européen puisque c'est les Français qui
ont fait bouger le règlement
méthane et puis évidemment toute la
partie adaptation peut apparaître comme
insuffisante par rapport aux besoins et
à la réalité des besoins des pays en en
développement néanmoins ces résultats
ambitieux sont le fruit d'un travail de
conviction et de construction de la
confiance avec les pays du Sud je l' dit
d'abord en investissant un très gros
effort diplomatique pour trouver un
accord sur le fond perte et préjudice
qui vise à mieux accompagner les pays
les plus vulnérables victimes de
catastrophes naturell alors qu'ils ne
sont pas les responsables du
réchauffement climatique chacun l'a
reconnu la France a joué un rôle clé
dans le compromis qui a permis d'adopter
ce fond perte et préjudice le premier
jour de la COP 28 et là aussi c'est un
accord historique au sens où c'est la
première fois que le premier jour d'une
COP on a un accord sur un point
essentiel du de l'accord ce fond sera
doté de près de 700 millions de dollars
de promesse de don la France y
participera jusqu'à 100 millions d'euros
euh c'est la rédaction ou la le propos
du président parce que nous voulons
garder la main aussi sur la manière dont
ce fond fonctionnera cette adoption
rapide et ces annonces ont permis de
concentrer ensuite tous nos efforts sur
la question de la sortie des énergies
fossiles deuxième brique de la
construction le fait de réitérer
l'engagement des 100 milliards de
dollars et qui est atteint ces deux
dernières années pour faire face au
dérèglement climatiques quand je dis ces
deux dernières années c'est 2022 et 2023
la France y contribue à hauteur de 7,76
milliards d'euros en 2022 3ème brique
les contacts étroits que j'ai noué avec
le groupe des pays et le président
évidemment les moins avancés
présidé par le Bangladesh avec le Kenya
avec les pays latino-américains
progressistes comme la Colombie ou le
Chili avec le Brésil qui a été
instrumental puisque c'est un pays
émergent qui a manifesté un fort
leadership diplomatique ce qui est
relativement nouveau mais aussi avec mes
homologues chinois indiens saoudiens
pour les convaincre de se rallier un
accord qui était moins évident pour eux
mais qui nous fixe clairement un cadre
collectif de responsabilité permettant
de sortir de manière organisée des
énergies fossiles et en tenant compte du
point de départ de chacun nous avons
ainsi construit une coalition de plus de
130 pays qui a largement pesé dans les
résultats obtenus sur la sortie des
énergies fossiles et qui sortaiit des
groupes habituels et donc des face à
face habituelle entre sud et Nord
collectivement nous avons travaillé très
dur pour arriver à ce résultat je veux
féliciter saluer toutes les équipes de
négociateurs français vous savez qu'il y
a plus de 30 50 personnes
qui ont travaillé pour pour cet accord
on peut se féliciter d'avoir une des
très bonnes équipes de négociation je
pense à l'ambassadeur climat Stéphane
cruza je pense à au négociateurs de
l'accord perte et préjudice et ça a
permis de maintenir un haut niveau
d'ambition pour conclure la crise
climatique ne va pas s'effacer du jour
au lendemain avec cet accord on en est
tout à fait convaincu il va falloir
travailler très dur à coup l'année
prochaine pour la COP 29 et surtout à
Bélem au Brésil pour la COP 30 il faut
aller plus loin notamment sur la
solidarité avec les pays du Sud sur
l'adaptation sur la justice climatique
mais je crois pouvoir dire que la France
et l'Union européennes ont réussi à
construire des fondations de partenariat
solides et
que par la suite de notre diplomatie
climatique qui va prendre des formes
très claires à partir du début d'année
nous allons continuer à entretenir ce
que nous avons commencé à construire
avec le président de la République qui
va permettre je pense d'aller plus loin
en particulier à Bélen merci beaucoup
madame la ministre nous arrivons donc
aux orateurs des groupes pour le groupe
Renaissance la parole est à Marjoline
mier milfer merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues madame la ministre
félicitations les de semaines de
négociation et de travaux qui se sont
tenus à la COP 28 ont déjoué les
pronostics les plus pessimiste pour la
première fois depuis tris décennies les
combustibles fossiles à l'origine de 80
% des émissions de gaz à effet de ser
figure dans un accord issu de
négociation climatique vous avez
remarquablement résisté aux pressions et
ce texte constitue indéablement une
victoire tout d'abord c'est la première
fois qu'un accord appelle à la sortie
progressive des énergies fossiles en
cohérence avec l'objectif de 1 der5
point cardinal de l'accord de Paris pour
le climat de plus en écho au choix de la
France ce texte donne une place inédite
à la contribution de l'énergie nucléaire
dans la lutte contre le changement
climatique et ouvre la voie à une
multiplication par trois des énergies
renouvelables enfin soulignons que cet
accord enclenche concrètement la
dynamique de la justice climatique avec
adoption du fond pertes et projets
judice pour les pays les plus
vulnérables même si ce fond devra
vraisemblablement être renforcé sa
concrétisation est une victoire madame
la ministre quand on se bat pour le
climat il faut fêter les victoires et
retourner au travail dès le lendemain
vous y êtes déjà pouvez-vous nous citer
les prochaines actions de la France dans
son suivi des engagements pris à Dubaï
et dans sa volonté d'enclencher les
futures négociations quels sont nos
leviers pour accélérer la sortie des
énergies fossiles chez nos partenaires
pouvez-vous nous parler des partenariats
climats bilatéraux tels que suis signé
avec l'Afrique du Sud en mars 2021 de
quel levier de diplomatie
environnementale disposons-nous en
dehors des COP la COP 28 fut aussi
l'occasion pour les gouvernements
français et marocains de lancer le
building breakthrough en collaboration
avec le programme des nations- Unies
pour l'Environnement ce projet engage à
faire du bâtiment résilient et
bascarbone la nouvelle norme mondiale
pour 203 2030 et il rassemble dors et
déjà 27 pays signataires pour amplifier
cette démarche le gouvernement a décidé
de lancer le premier Forum mondial sur
les bâtiments et le climat le secteur du
bâtiment et de la construction passe
pour près de 40 % des émissions
mondiales on le rappelle ce sera le
prochain grand rendez-vous climat
mondial il se tiendra les 7 et 8 mars
2024 à Paris on y attend une soixantaine
de de pays madame la
ministreattendez-vous de ce sommet qui
place la France comme l'un des leaders
dans la décarbonation des bâtiments je
vous remercie merci pour le groupe la
France insoumise nupes la parole est à
Anne Steinbach
teroir merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre donc hier vous nous
avez martelé en hémicycle à quel point
cet accord est un accord historique et
en un sens c'est pas faux parce que je
pense que les générations futures le
regarderont en se disant mais comment
ont-ils pu comment ont-ils pu dans un
monde qui se dirigeit vers un
réchauffement à + 4°gr organiser la COP
28 à Dubaï empire pétrolier symbole de
ce que le capitalisme engendrait de pire
avec 2500 lobbyistes des énergies
fossiles qui veillaient au grain comment
ont-ils pu avaler que le gaz était une
énergie de transition alors que c'est
une énergie fossile comment ont-ils pu
se féliciter d'un accord tellement pas
contraignant que même total énergie le
salut
manuel Macron a déclaré la priorité des
priorités est que les pays les plus
avancés sortent des énergies fossiles
mais on a vraiment pas de quoi faire des
leçons au monde en fait il nous annonce
la sortie du charbon pour 2027 waouh
quelle ambition attendez c'était pas
déjà prévu pour 2022 ah ben si mais
finalement on a ouvert une centrale à
charbon l'an dernier et on annonce huit
nouveaux puits de pétrole dans la forêt
de La Teste de bûche en Gironde et vous
n'avez rien à en dire alors je sais
qu'orico l'accord mentionne le nucléaire
et en prime une vingtaine de pays sont
engagés à tripler la production
nucléaire d'ici 2050 sauf qu'on est en
situation d'urgence et que promettre une
baisse rapide des gaz à effet de Cers
grâce au nucléaire ben en fait c'est
mentir aux gens il y a un rapport
indépendant sur l'état de l'industrie
nucléaire mondiale qui estime que le
triplement des capacités c'est très
irréalist très irréaliste compte tenu
des longs délaiis de construction des
centrales nucléaires et même le PDG
d'ODF le dit un premier pr PR2 pour 2037
c'est optimiste comme scénario or
pendant ces 15 ans au mieux là où on
attend que le premier réacteur sort de
terre ben il se passe rien nos émissions
de gaz à effet de s ne baissent pas le
CO2 continue de s'accumuler et la
température continue de monter 15 ans on
n plus le temps d'attendre et là au lieu
d'investir massivement dans les EnR dans
une politique de sobriété on bloque des
milliards dans des réacteurs dont on ne
maîtrise pas encore la technique encore
moins le traitement des déchets et qu'on
ne pourra peut-être même plus refroidir
quand ils seront là comp tenu de la
raréfaction de l'eau donc oui la COP 28
c'est une occasion manquée historique
une de plus alors qu'on fonce à toute
vitesse dans le mur
climatique pour les républicains la
parole est à Antoine Vermorel marquez
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues madame la ministre avant d'en
venir au fond je voudrais revenir sur
votre esprit partisan et quelque peu
provocateur vous nous avez accusé
d'inaction en disant on met les chiffres
alors risque de vous déplaire je
voudrais ici vous rappeler votre bilan
l'arrêt de la centrale de fessenhe le 30
juin 2020 ce n'est pas nous la fin du du
projet de 4e génération nucléaire astr
en 2019 ce n'est pas nous l'objectif de
réduire à 50 % la part du nucléaire dans
la production électrique du pays en 2035
ce n'est pas nous et la réouverture des
centrales à charbon le 6 février 2022 ce
n'est pas nous je crois que nous av'ons
pas de leçon à recevoir et maintenant
que nous avons parlé du passé nous
pouvons nous tourner donc vers l'avenir
la COP 28 qui vient de se clore à Dubaï
fait pour la première fois référence à
une transition hors des énergies
fossiles la France y voit un synonyme de
sortie est-ce tout à fait la même chose
notre mix énergétique reste encore
dominé à 37 % par le pétrole d'abord
pour les transports et à 21 % par le gaz
surtout pour le logement quel volume
d'électricité et de chaleur renouvelable
nous faudra-t-il pour réussir à se
passer de leur usage pouvez-vous
préciser l'allusion faite par Emmanuel
Macron la semaine dernière au lancement
de H réacteurs supplémentaires en plus
des six actuellement prévus au titre du
nouveau nucléaire seriez-vous prêt à
inscrire ces cibles dans la loi de
programmation énergie climat et surtout
quand celle-ci nous sera-telle présenté
l'Union européenne n'a pas soutenu
l'appel de la France à tripler la
production mondiale de nucléaire comment
poursuivre une coopération européenne
efficace tant que les intérêts allemands
et français continueront de diverger en
la matière le gaz a également été au
cœur des discussions à Dubaï comment
concilier le statut d'énergie de
transition qui lui est accordé et la
sortie des énergies fossiles sur quelles
alternatives misez-vous pour le
remplacer alors que la France a
largement fait appel au GNL et au gaz
Algériens pour parer aux conséquences de
la guerre en Ukraine pour ce qui est du
charbon ayant récemment déposé une
proposition de loi C par Olivier marleti
et les députés républicains visant à
proscrire le recours à ce dernier comme
source de production d'énergie
électrique je me réjouis que le
gouvernement a défendu la sortie du
charbon à Dubaï alors que le Président
de la République vient de reporter cet
objectif à 2027 comment la France
compte-elle incarner cette position
enfin les États ont acté lors de la COP
28 que le nucléaire l'hydrogène et le
captage au carbone étaient des solutions
en matière de transition quelle mesure
la France compte-elle donc prendre pour
soutenir le progrès technique en matière
de transition environnementale je vous
remerci merci pour le groupe démocrate
modem et indépendant la parole est à
Michel Cosson
bonjour monsieur le président madame la
ministre je souhais tout d'abord me
réjouir des avancées marquées par cette
COP 28 malgré les nombreux signaux
contraires initiaux un rendez-vous dans
un pays producteur de pétrole et des
membres de l'OPEP qui ont voulu faire
pression pour entraver un accord
ambitieux c'est la suite logique de la
COP 21 qui s'était tenue à Paris cet
accord fait enfin mention de la
nécessaire réduction puis sortie des
énergies fossiles comme le pétrole ou le
gaz sou temp faire partie des optimistes
madame la ministre je voudrais tout de
même vous interroger sur la terminologie
terminologie
employée si le texte retient
actuellement la mention de transition
hors des énergies fossiles dans les
systèmes énergétiques estimez-vous
possible que dès les prochaines COP on
puisse aboutir à la mention d'abandon de
ces
énergies la réduction des émissions de
méthane a été l'un des facteurs
importants de cette COP pourriez-vous
revenir sur les engagements des sociétés
pétrolières et gazières pour réduire les
émissions de méthane à un niveau proche
de zéro d'ici 2030 et arrêter le
torchage du gaz naturel et nous préciser
les engagements de la France à ce niveau
je souhaitais aussi vous interroger
également sur les 30 pays qui ont signé
une reconnaissance mutuelle des
certificats d'hydrogène propre comment
la France se positionne-t-elle sur ce
point et serons-nous amener comme les
Allemands à importer de l'hydrogène vert
produit sur d'autres
continents enfin un mot sur l'objectif
de tripler les les capacités de NR pour
dépasser le sujet de cette COP et
aborder le différents avec l'Union
européenne sur nos objectifs de
production ISS des renouvelables
pourriezous pourriez-vous nous faire un
point sur cette situation enfin nous
savons combien nous avons été euh en
difficulté face à la souveraineté
énergétique et ma question sera
justement sur l'hydrogène vert quelles
ambitions pour la France et enfin euh en
milieu rural euh quel est votre regard
sur la biométhanisation à l'échelle des
exploitations pour non seulement qu'il
puissent assurer leur souveraineté
énergétique en milieu rurale et pour la
filière agricole mais également qu'
puisse diminuer leur impact
environnemental merci chers collègu pour
le groupe socialiste et apparenté la
parole est à Stéphane de laotrette merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
j'irai droite au but si nous pouvons
nous féliciter que pour la première fois
le projet de décision d'une COP
reconnaisse la nécessité de s'éloigner
des combustibles fossile nous ne pouvons
considérer cet accord comme historique
et je me permets d'autant plus de le
dire et je vous le rappelle madame la
ministre nous avons travaillé et voté
avec vous le texte accélération sur les
énergies renouvelables or forceé de
constater aujourd'hui que les
discussions les décrets soumis à
discussion ne sont pas à la hauteur des
promesses que vous nous aviez faites au
moment de ce travail pour en revenir à
la COP cette COP a permis de montrer le
décalage entre les engagements des états
et ce qui serait nécessaire pour limiter
le réchauffement climatique proche des
1,5°gr le texte ne fixe ni objectif ni
calendrier de sortie des énergies
fossiles or le dernier rapport du GC
précise que pour respecter les accords
de Paris l'utilisation du charbon doit
être réduite de 95 % dans le monde
entier celle du pétrole de 60 % et celle
du gaz de 45 % d'ici 2050 en résumé cet
accord ne semble pas programmer la fin
des énergies fossiles mais semble
justifier au contraire de les conserver
un peu plus c'est ce que fait votre
gouvernement la sortie du charbon on
déjà promis pour 2022 et désormais
reporté en septembre dernier en 2027
alors que notre pays fait face à des
besoins d'électrification massif que
notre parc nucléaire est vieissant et
que l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables peine à compenser nos
besoins accrus en électricité c'est
pourquoi mon groupe réitère ici la
volonté de débattre d'une loi de
programmation énergétique et d'une autre
portée que les textes qui nous sont
imposés tels que celui voté hier c'est
l'unique moyen de nous assurer
collectivement que nous sortirons bien
des énergies fossiles tout tout en
construisant un cadre propice au
développement des énergies décarbonées
alors madame la ministre à quand une
grande loi de programmation énergétique
merci pour le groupison et apparenté la
parole est à Vincent
thébau merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
il y a quelques jours c'est achevé donc
cette 28e conférence des partis à la
convention cadre des des Nations unies
sur changement climatique la C 28 8 ans
après la COP 21 et l'adoption historique
de l'accord de Paris pour le climat nous
pouvons ici nous féliciter de cette 28e
édition qui représente une étape
déterminante de la lutte contre le
changement climatique cela a été évoqué
de nombreuses avancées ont été engagé de
lors de C 28 et je tiens à rappeler que
la France et l'Union européenne ont
supporté une position exigeante et
volontariste durant les négociation
d'abord vous le savez nous pouvons nous
féliciter de l'accord historique relatif
à la sortie progressive des énergies
fossiles et qui nous permettra d'une
part d'atteindre neutalité carbone d'ici
2050 et d'autre part de respecter
l'objectif de limitation de changement
de réchauffement climatique à 1,5°gr
fixé par l'accord de Paris à ce titre je
tenais à vous saluer votre travail
madame la ministre et l'ensemble des de
de vos collaborateurs qui vous
accompagnz durant ces 3 jours nous
devons maintenant mettre en le
pleinement ce plan en tant que
parlementaire nous serons attentifs je
voudrais aussi saluer votre travail et
votre ténacité parce qu'il est facile de
critiquer qu'on est assis au fond d'une
salle à Paris alors que nous avons à
faire effectivement vous étiez au
contact de 130 pays qui va tous
effectivement des obligations exigences
et quand j'entends certains collègues fa
peut-être le rappeler que la France est
66 millions d'habitants dans le monde
700 milliards et il faut arrê 7
milliards pardon et il faut arrêter de
croire que nous pouvons fixer nos
exigences au monde entier par ailleurs
nous pouvons nous réjouir de l'ambition
de tripler des énergies renouvlable dans
le monde d'ici 2030 et de la
reconnaissance du rôle clé d'énergie
nucléaire qui vont dans le sens
d'engagement prix pour la majorité il y
a quelques
mois madame ministre je meficite du
travailie excusez-moi je vais partir par
sinon je vais
m'énerver chers collègues s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît pour les
écologistes nu P la parole est à Marie
pochon on évite de s'invectiver s'il
vous plaît chers
collègu vous avez la parole Marie
poochon merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre 13 décembre 2023 deux
titres de presse pour le ministère
l'accord de la COP 28 envoie un message
très fort au marché sur la sortie des
fossiles accord de la COP 28 total
énergie applaudit et se réjouit de la
mention du gaz comme énergie de
transition deux salles deux ambiances
apparemment c'est à se demander si vous
étiez à la même COP 28 mais bien sûr que
vous étiez ensemble puisque après avoir
donné la Légion d'honneur au PDG total
Energie la France l'acrédité dans sa
délégation un lobbyiste des fossiles de
plus au milieu de 2500 autres lobby des
fossiles sur place là-bas madame la
ministre il nous déclare la guerre alors
que l'impératif de CER tout nouveau
projets fossiles est matraqué par les
scientifiques le transitioning away les
énergies de transition les recours au
captage font la joie des industries et
pays pétrolier alors nous écologistes
savons que nous avons besoin de ces
plateformes internationales de
coconstruction des solutions où chaque
pays du plus puissant au plus faible
peut faire entendre sa voix face au
défis le plus immense auquel notre
humanité n''est jamais été confrontée
quel est c'est la voix de la France
madame la ministre étaitce celle de
l'intégration de la sortie de toutes les
énergies fossiles charbon pétrole et gaz
alors que vous avez fait ces
négociations une plateforme de com pour
vos Luis nucléaires tout en annonçant
des nouveaux forrages pétroliers en
Gironde alors que le face down remplace
le face out si nécessaire était-ce la
voie du traité de non prolifération des
énergies fossiles ou de l'abandon des
bombes climatiques comme icop alors que
vous les soutenez et empêchez les
députés de soutenir ces mesures était
celle des solutions de transition comme
la sob la réduction de l'aviation ou de
la consommation de viande là non plus
impossible car votre majorité va jusqu'à
s'opposer à l'option végétarienne dans
les cantines madame la ministre la
France a une voix dans ses négociations
une voix cruciale sera-t-elle demain
celle qui soutiendra le traité de non
prolifération des énergies fossiles et
qui cessera de soutenir les bombes
climatiques de ces majors ou bien est
trop P vinaigre je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outrem et territoire la
parole est à gu
bricou
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre à l'issue de cette COP 28 on
peut je pense se féliciter qu'elle est
permis de déterminer une grande ligne
directrice qui tente à mettre tous les
acteurs en ordre de marche malgré des
intérêts particulièrement divergents
pour s'extraire progressivement des
énergies fossiles on est au-delà du
symbole une ligne est tracée et on
n'imagine pas que certains pourraient
désormais faire machine arrière c'est
donc bon signe c'est une bonne inflexion
madame la ministre cette nouvelle cop
s'est tenu dans un climat mondial de
crise toujours plus sévère guerre
catastrophe économique climatique
comment cela se traduit-il dans ces
négociations les experts n'arrêtent pas
de nous alerter sur l'urgence et les
plus prignantees que jamais aujourd'hui
à l'issu de cette COP peut-on encore
imaginer que nous pourrons accélérer le
mouvement pour ne pas atteindre un
réchauffement global de
1,5°g ctigr selon l'ancienne
co-présidente du GC Valérie maasson
delmot si on réalisait toutes les
promesse cela ne permettrait une baisse
que de 5 % des
gaz gaz à effet de serre alors que pour
limiter le réchauffement largement sous
les 2 degrés degr il faudrait une baisse
de 43 % dès lors comment composer au
niveau national avec un tel échec
annoncé comment avez-vous précisément
ressenti l'investissement de la Chine
dans ces négociations alors qu'elle a pu
être perçue comme assez constructive ou
facilitatrice ce sont des mots qui
revenaient souvent dans la bouche les
commentateurs pouvez-vous nous expliquer
la manière dont elle a effectivement
influé sur ce sommet at-elle donné une
vraie impulsion et sur quel point
a-t-elle bloqué comment percevez-vous
madame la ministre au lendemain de cette
COP l'engagement des entreprises qui
sont des acteurs clé de notre transition
énergétique et enfin que pensez-vous du
fait qu'il n'y ait toujours pas de
sanction prévu pour les pays qui ne
suivrai pas les engagements qu'ils ont
signés citons ainsi l'accord non
contraignant signé le 2 décembre qui
vise à tripler les capacités de
renouvelabl dans le monde d'ici 2030 ne
risquet-on pas comme trop souvent de
s'arrêter à une bonne intention merci
merci et enfin pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine je vais
laisser la parole à Jean-Victor castor
en rendant un hommage je pense qu'on
peut tous lui rendre à Hubert vulfran
qui a fait son pot de départ hier et ce
n'est pas adieu ce n'est qu'un au revoir
mais on pense bien à à Hubert au moment
où je m'exprime cher Jean-Victor castor
la parole est à vous bonjour tout le
monde bonjour président madame la
ministre en fait moi je vais intervenir
comme presque un porte-parole des pays
du Sud parce que la Guyane c'est un pays
du Sud
sousdéveloppé en pleine
Amazonie pays totalement oublié non
aménagé confronté à le paayage illégal
je l'ai déjà dit et je vous avais
expliqué
il y a quelques mois de ça que partir
dans les copes euh pour la diplomatie
française c'est aussi d'avoir balayé
devant sa porte et en réalité ce qui se
passe en Guyane c'est un scandale donc
il y a une mission donc de la commission
Développement Durable qui est parti du
16 au 22 il y a un rapport je vous
invite à le lire madame madame la
ministre parce que on ne peut pas faire
de la diplomatie internationale sans
tenir compte d'une certaine d'un certain
nombre de réalités aujourd'hui sur le
plateau des Guyanes il y a un
développement hors norme
de enfin de l'exploitation de l'énergie
fossile le Venezuela le savait le Guyana
c'est énorme ce qui se passe au suinam
monsieur puyane vient de signer avec un
budget de près de 9 milliards donc
d'investissement au Surinam pétrobrass
au Brésil à 1 heure de la Guyane en fait
euh la Guyane est elle est un petit peu
comme les pays du Sud sauf que nous
sommes nous faisons partie intégrante de
la France en tous les cas c'est ce qui
est dit mais on ne voit pas le retour et
on ne voit pas cette solidarité donc ce
que je veux dire ici c'est que il est
très important de de comprendre que les
peuples les peuples du Sud ont besoin de
se développer ce ne son ce ne sont pas
les peuples du Sud qui ont pollué la
planète ce ne sont pas les peuples du
Sud qui ont pollué la planète ce ne sont
pas les peuples autochtones qui ont
pollué la planète aujourd'hui c'est eux
qui subissent les conséquences donc donc
effectivement nous devons prendre en
compte ce qui s'est passé dans le monde
mais la diplomatie et bientôt il y aura
donc effectivement une CM moi j'aimerais
savoir si les guanais feront partie de
la délégation si nous serons présents et
si notre parole portera dans cette
délégation merci madame la ministre je
vous laisse le soin de répondre et si on
veut tenir le timing c'estàd partir que
vous puissiez partir à 9h55 peêtre faire
des réponses très synthétique puisque
nous avons d'ors et déjà une dizaine de
questions merci beaucoup je vais faire
aussi synthétique que possible mais en
même temps j'ai des questions à tiroirs
multiples donc je faut que j'arrive à
vous répondre aussi oui les Guyanais
feront partie de de la délégation de béê
pour la bonne et simple raison que tout
Français qui est engagé ou a un rapport
avec la COP 28 obtient une accréditation
ça c'est pour un petit peu et donc vous
avez des guyané dans la délégation
française et 800 personnes dans la
délégation française 800 personnes et il
y a 250 personnes qui ont accès qui qui
participe aux négociations et donc il ne
faut pas confondre ceux qui parce qu'ils
sont français demandent une délégation
qui soit étudiant dans des entreprise ou
dans
chercheurs députés d'ailleurs parce que
moi j'ai j'ai accueilli des des députés
et des et des sénateurs qui parce qu'ils
sont français demandent à avoir une
accréditation pour aller à la COP 28
donc ça c'est pour répondre à tous ceux
qui font les lobbyistes et cetera les
lobbyistes ils ne négocient pas les
lobbyistes peuvent éventuellement ou en
tout cas les représentants des
entreprises sont pour faire des
événements ils explique qu'ils vont
s'engager à baisser les émissions de gaz
et effet de serre et cet élément de
langage est franchement pas au niveau de
ce qui est une COP alors Marjoline
milire prochaine action de la France
travailler sur des plans résiliences
avec des pays qui sont confrontés à sont
au première loge je dirais de la
transformation du dérèglement climatique
on travaille notamment avec le
Bangladesh deuxième chose des
partenariats bilatéraux vous l'avez
mentionné on en a un sur le nucléaire
triplement du nucléaire d'ici 2050 hein
c'est pas la semaine prochaine on tient
bien en compte de du temps de
développement du nucléaire partenariat
sur le green shipping le transport
maritime vert partenariat sur le charbon
sur lequel le président de la République
s'est fortement engagé comment très vite
on réduit le charbon on sort du charbon
on accompagne les pays qui ferment des
centrales à charbon qui doivent
accompagner socialement et
économiquement leur pays c'est ce qu'on
fait d'ailleurs avec le partenariat que
vous mentionnez euh qui y a un jetp avec
l'Afrique du Sud on a 1 milliard d'euros
engagé sur 5 ans pour permettre à
l'Afrique du Sud d'accélérer sa sortie
du char et au total c'est 8,5 milliards
de dollars de financement pour
accompagner la sortie du du charbon dans
différents pays le Vietnam l'Indonésie
le
Sénégal sur le building breakthrough qui
a été engagé avec le Maroc l'objectif
c'est des du prochain sommet c'est de se
mettre d'accord sur des objectifs
communs de décarbonation du bâtiment
avec une déclaration de tous les pays
présent dans ce
sens et sur le financement c'est
continuer à dérouler l'agenda de Paris
avec à l'occasion de chaque
événement G7 G20 âgé des nations- Unies
et en créant des coalitions plus
spécifiques continent par continent
comme on l'a fait
depuis depuis Paris en juin dernier
madame stembar Terrenoire je pense que
vous avez une présentation
extraordinairement caricaturale de ce
qui est une négociation à la COP j'ai
répondu sur les participants je rappelle
que de mai il n'était pas question de le
fermer en 2022 donc ça c'est pour
m'inscrire en fau contre un certain
nombre de fake news que vous contribuez
à disséminer dans l'atmosphère oui on
est capable de faire FO 3 d'ici 2050 en
nucléaire je rappelle qu'on fera plus 40
% d'ici 2030 parce que il y a un certain
nombre de nations qui sont engagées dans
le nucléaire et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que 196 pays s'engagent dans le
nucléaire alors probablement vous avez
raison contre tous les pays du monde
mais je me permets de le signaler a
priori 195 16 pays et les responsables
politiques de ces 196 pays considèrent
que l'énergie nucléaire est une énergie
bac carbone et qui contribue à la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et en
plus vous le faites alors que votre
groupe et je distingue bien les groupes
qui votent la loi accélération des
énergies renouvelables et les groupes
qui ne votent pas la loi accélération
des énergies renouvelables je le
distingue bien et au sein de l'anups il
y a des groupes qui ont voté la loi et
des groupes qui ne l'ont pas voté et je
le dis très clairement certains ont pris
leur resp responsabilité d'autres font
de l'écologie de pacotille en disant
faut pas faire c faut pas faire ça mais
à la fin ils sont pas au
rendez-vous sur la baisse des émissions
de gaz et effet de serre vous dites que
ça augmente s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît vous dites que ça augmente ça
baisse de 4,6 % trouvez-moi un pays dans
le monde un seul pays dans le monde qui
baisse ses émissions de gaz et effet de
serre de 4,6 % ces trois derniers
trimestres sur s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît min s'il vous plaît on est
respectueux on dit les faits c'est juste
ça monsieur le
député monsieur Vermorel marquez alors
transition away versus face out là je ne
sais pas encore quelle sera la
traduction française nous on l'attend
transition and phase c'est la même chose
c'est une sortie ENF pardon c'est un
c'est un exercice phasé transition et
phase vous avez la même notion de
ordonner et Phaser out et way dans ma
modeste maîtrise de l'anglais c'està dit
la même chose et transition way call
c'est quelque chose que l'on retrouve
comme sortie du charbon est-ce que cette
traduction sera retenue en français on
pourra en discuter quand on aura le
texte je mon sentiment très clair c'est
que ça n'a rien à voir avec du face down
puisque c'est comme ça que nous l'avons
obtenu il est très clair que ce n'est
pas du face down c'est de l'ordre du
face out le face out étant un mot qui
était devenu très tabou je pense que
tous autour de cette table on
l'expérience de la légistique et des
mots qu'on ne peut pas introduire sur
lequel on fait des des contournements
par amendement pour obtenir des choses
un peu
similaires comprendront ce que je veux
dire c'est de la même nature que lorsque
vous portez un amendement et que vous
allez faire un pas de côté pour obtenir
votre objectif final en terme de de
résultat quel volume d'électricité de
chaleur c'est un peu trop long mais je
vous renvoie la stratégie françaiseg
éergie climat qui est publique que vous
avez contribué à construire et qui est
sur lequel nous sommes en concertation
publique et je je rappelle que vous avez
évidemment la la faculté de d'y
participer à tous les titres en tant
qu'élu local en tant que voilà en tant
que député aussi évidemment 6 + 8
réacteur nucléaire c'est donc un
engagement de construction de six
réacteurs plus additionnels qui sont à
l'étude et sur lequel la prise de
position est attendue pour fin 202 6 en
terme de décision d'engagement
d'investir euh l'Union européenne ne
s'est pas rallié effectivement à la
déclaration nucléaire mais les pays de
l'alliance du nucléaire se sont ralliés
à cette déclaration et comme vous le
savez j'avais réuni hier l'alliance du
nucléaire européenne en présence de la
Commission européenne et l'objectif
c'est de construire une stratégie
nucléaire et la directrice de l'énergie
DG énergie de la Commission européenne
nous a invité à mettre nos objectifs de
nucléaire dans nos plans nationals
énergie climat c'était tout à fait
légitime de le faire donc je pense qu'on
a un vrai une vraie avancée sur ça sur
Net zero industry Act aussi on prend en
compte le nucléaire donc clairement le
logiciel est en train de de bouger sur
le gaz effectivement il est alors il
n'est pas cité en tant que tel mais on
mentionne des énergies de de transition
et c'est notamment un besoin qui est
formulé par les pays en développement
qui pour basculer du charbon aux
énergies renouvelables auront
probablement besoin d'une phase euh gaz
naturel qui est moins ém qui émet
beaucoup moins de CO2 que le charbon
c'est ça qui est derrière ça et est en
tête que les pays qui ont été les plus
vocaux aussi contre la sortie des
énergies fossiles c'est les pays
africains euh en développement les plus
pauvres qui disent j'ai besoin de moyens
de développement c'est ce que vous avez
dit d'ailleurs monsieur le député en en
signalant la situation de la Guyane et
de vos voisins qui revendiquent d'une
certaine manière d'avoir des moyens de
développement donc il disent très bien
donnez-moi ces moyens de développement
si vous me privez de l'accès à un moyen
de développement naturel qui est les
énergies fossile et je pense que ce
débat il doit être adressé vous avez
parfaitement raison sur le charbon c'est
le je rappelle que CORDEM c'était bien
une sortie en 2027 sur les CCUS vous
avez un plan CCUS qui a été publié par
Roland lescur et moi-même avec notamment
des soutiens sachant que notre stratégie
CCUS c'est pas une stratégie tout venant
mais c'est une stratégie réservée aux
secteurs les plus difficiles enfin dans
lesquel les la baisse des émissions est
la plus difficile parce que nous
estimons que les le CCUS ne la capture
carbone ne répondra pas à tous les
usages et que le risque c'est que ce
soit un prétexte pour retarder le moment
de la sortie des énergies fossiles donc
on a une version équilibré on va dire
sur le CCUS mais on soutient bien le
CCUS dans notre stratégie industrielle
et et climatique
euh monsieur Cosson les prochaines copes
oui on est bien dans la notion déjà
d'abandon des énergies fossiles les
engagements des sociétés pétrolières ils
ont été pris en en dans des coalitions
qui sont latérales dans lequel les
entreprises européennes et un certain
nombre de grandes entreprises national
je pense à celle de l'Arabie Saoudite
celle de des Émirats arabes unis ont
signé ses engagements ce n'est pas le
cas de tous les groupes pétroliers de la
planète il faut élargir ce point-là et
notamment aller vers une interdiction du
torchage à horizon 2030 parce que c'est
des gains rapides sur la reconnaissance
mutuelle de certificat hydrogène propre
et surtout l'importation d'hydrogène là
aussi je vous renvoie à la stratégie
française énergie climat on répond à
cette question nous avons 2/3 de notre
mix énergétique importé nous ne saurons
pas du jour au lendemain le remplacer
par des productions
locale et donc une partie de notre
hydrogène sera importé mais nous voulons
être en capacité de produire nous-même
de l'hydrogène pour éviter d'être dans
une situation de dépendance totale comme
on est par exemple sur le pétrole où 99
% plus de 99 % de notre pétrole est
importé tac tac sur sur la
biométanisation je me permets aussi de
vous renvoyer sur la stratégie française
énergie climat tous les chiffres sont
dedans sur monsieur le puté de le traite
je ne me trompe pas sur les unr vous
avez voté en responsabilité ce texte
vous l'avez voté et vous y avez
introduit des choses sur les décrets ne
peuvent pas aller à l'encontre du texte
donc je sais pas à quoi vous faites
référence mais il y a bien à la ah
l'agrivoltaïsme donc ça on pourra en
parler latéralement je on en a beaucoup
parlé avec votre
collègue le député potier je pense que
c'est un juste équilibre qu'on a trouvé
et que que il y a parfois des
contrevérités qui peuvent
circuler le l'objectif dans le texte COP
28 est bien chiffré - 43 % de baisse des
émissions de gaz et effet de serre en
2030 un pic en 2025 et une sortie en
2050 c'est écrit noir sur blanc et à
plusieurs endroits du
texte et donc sur la stratégie française
énergie climat je vous je vous renvoie à
ce qui est déjà sur la table depuis le
23 novembre et quel vous avez d'ailleurs
tout à fait contribué à que vous avez
contribué à nourrir je dis pas que vous
êtes d'accord avec tout mais vous avez
contribué à le nourrir monsieur th
madame pochon
euh enfin quand on vote pas la loi sur
les énergies renouvelables je sais pas à
quel titre on parle d'écologie enfin je
voilà mais pour répondre mais oui mais
si mais pour répondre pour répondre sur
la sortie des énergies fossiles s'il
vous plaît pour répondre sur la sortie
des énergies fossiles non vous pouvez
dire il faut accélérer sur les énergies
renouvelables et pas voter la loi qui
accélère les énergies
renouvelables je je je permets de point
vous aurez l'occasion non mais s'il vous
plaît vous aurez l'occasion de réagir
dans un second temps s'il vous plaît
donc Madame la Ministre
répond vous prenez la parole juste après
d'accord mais il faut être
cohérent faut être cohérent c'est juste
je suis pour les énergies renouvelables
je les accélère je suis contre les
énergies renouvelables je ne les
accélère pas ça me paraît assez logique
comme logici
le Crédit Agricole pour vous donner un
exemple à annoncer suite au texte de la
COP 28 qu'il sortez ces financements des
énergies fossiles donc est-ce que
concrètement ça produit des effets oui
et ça produit des effets en France et
donc ce n'est pas un faceed qui est dans
le texte ce que vous dites est inexact
sur la sobriété
elle est dans le texte de la COP 28
c'est pas inintéressant de le savoir et
je rappelle que c'est ce gouvernement
qui a apporté un plan de sobriété et qui
a permis de baisser les euh la
consommation de gaz et d'électricité de
12 % de manière combinée et que c'est
pas tout à fait étranger à la baisse de
4,6 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre depuis le début de l'année donc
vous voyez bien que un certain nombre de
vos propos en fait sont assez infondés
confrontés à la réalité des faits
monsieur le député
bricou pour arriver au 1 der5 il faut
que chaque pays augmente ses engagements
nationaux c'est
national determin contribution c'est ce
que nous faisons en européen pour nous
mettre sur la trajectoire des 1 degr 5
et c'est ce que nous poussons à faire
avec les autres pays vous avez des pays
qui ont annoncé des augmentations de
leur contribution nationale mais c'est
évidemment vous avez complètement raison
l'enjeu des deux COP à venir pour être
crédible vous avez raison de parler de
multilatéralisme ce qu'il faut retenir
quand même aussi c'est que une grande
victoire du multilatéralisme dans un
moment de confrontation sur un différent
n sur différents continents et de
confrontation violentes sous forme de
conflit à haute intensité ou d'autres
formes de confrontation géopolitique
économique et et ça aussi je pense que
c'est à saluer je dirais globalement si
on prend un pas de côté au regard
au-delà de ce qui a pu être le rôle de
la France et c'est très important
comment la Chine a agi de ce que j'ai pu
en voir la Chine n'a pas été à la
manœuvre pour avoir un accord mais à
qu'un moment elle s'est elle a empêché
un accord et le texte sur lequel elle
s'est mis d'accord avec euh les
États-Unis en entrée enfin 2 semaines
avant la COP euh qui appelait à
substituer les énergies bac carbone aux
énergies fossile a clairement aidé aussi
à lancer la discussion dans la sortie
des énergies fossiles
euh alors euh oui l'accord de la COP est
un accord d'engagement volontaire ça n'a
pas la force euh de de enfin en tout cas
il n'y a pas de sanction euh c'est
parfaitement exact mais je rappelle que
cet accord finalement il joue puisque
vous êtes des
législateurs les législateurs dans
chaque pays s'appuient sur cet accord
pour peser sur les textes qui sont pris
au niveau national et c'est comme ça que
que cela fonctionne en réalité de même
que l'opinion publique peut s'appuyer
sur cet accord et c'est pour ça que nous
sommes passés d'un scénario de 4 degrés
en entrée d'accord de Paris à
aujourd'hui un scénario entre 2 degr 2
et 2 de 8 c'est peut-être pour
euh
sur sur le triplement des renouvelables
l'enjeu il est vraiment de les
développer dans les pays en
développement c'estàdire que la France
l'Europe la France l'Europe les
États-Unis la Chine sont partis la Chine
devrait mettre en ligne 1200 GW de
renouvelable quand vous regardez ce
qu'il y a en France c'est absolument
gigantesque c'est le tiers des capacités
mondiales installer avant 2030 ils
auront probablement 4 à 5 ans d'avance
par rapport à leur programme de
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
en revanche des projets dans des pays
africains qui permettent de produire de
l'électricité à 15 € du mgawh ce qui est
extraordinairement compétitif ne trouve
pas de financement et c'est là où il
faut absolument qu'on d'un point de vue
de financement on arrive à trouver la
façon de dérisquer ces projets et de
faire en sorte que le risque pays
n'empêche pas de faire des projets qui
sont bons pour la planète bons pour
l'économie de ces pays et bon
pour le le développement de de ces pays
euh sur je crois que j'ai répondu à
toutes vos questions oui monsieur le
député castor euh donc je l'ai dit vous
avez raison de signaler que les énergies
fossiles se développent à à proximité de
votre propre territoire de de la Guyane
et c'est bien le le le chemin critique
qu'est-ce qui a beaucoup saisi les ONG à
un moment c'est qu'il y ait une
déclaration des pays africains en
développant qui disent nous on veut pas
sortir des énergies fossiles on n pas
d'alternative de développement tant que
vous ne mettez pas une alternative de
développement sur la table on voit pas
pourquoi ce serait nous qui ferait des
efforts alors qu'on passe on pèse 4 %
des émissions de gaz et effet de serre
mondial et qu'on n' pas la
responsabilité historique du
réchauffement climatique inversement on
peut répondre à ça que si tous les
pays si tous les pays du
pardon si tous les pays développé
mettait à zéro leurs émissions de gaz à
effet de serre aujourd'hui il en
resterait 60 % dans l'atmosphère donc de
toute façon le le il y a la
responsabilité du passé et il y a ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui avec trois grands
tiers à réduire il y a un/ers pays
développés un/ers qui est la Chine mais
qui pèse 1,2 milliards de population et
un/ers qui sont tous les autres pays
avec notamment l'Inde qui pèse 1,4
milliards de population si on pose c'est
ça le le la chose que nous devons
affrontter et
euh les peuples c'est pas les peuples du
Sud qui ont pollué la planète et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut leur donner des
moyens des moyens d'aller de faire en
fait le saut par-dessus les énergies
fossiles et de développer directement
des énergies décarboné autant que
possible et par ailleurs d'être
accompagné financièrement dans leur
développement donc c'est le point
central et également l'adaptation parce
que vous êtes confronté au
euh au au au comment pardon aux tempêtes
aux cyclones et cetera il faut adapter
quand on construit des routes des
bâtiments quand on fait toute la partie
agriculture à ce réchauffement
climatique et ce que ça veut dire de
manière à ce que on puisse vous puissiez
le traverser nous puissons
collectivement le traverser de manière
plus enfin moins impactante pour les
populations
pardon alors je je vais devoir laisser
mais encore une fois on peut aussi se
parler vous avez surtout un volet qui
est biodiversité qui est majeur j'en ai
pas parlé nous estimons que la
biodiversité c'est la deuxième phase de
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et que les deux doivent être
totalement lié et que notamment les
investissements dans la nature et nous
en faisons beaucoup et nous en faisons
en Guyane il me semble-t-il de manière
très importante ce sont des
investissements qui ont une très forte
valeur ajoutée et un très fort retour
sur investissement mais qui sont pas
suffisamment mis en
valeur merci madame la ministre nous
avons une dizaine de questions donc on
on est bien dans le timing 9h30 on finit
les questions 9h40 et vous aurez un
quart d'heure pour pour répondre c'est
parfait question de Madame
brulbois merci monsieur le Président
merci madame la ministre pour votre
présentation parmi les actions à mettre
en œuvre outre le triplement des
énergies renouvelables d'ici 2030 et le
développement du nucléaire il y a des
des technologies de cap et de stockage
du carbone qui sont encore balbuantes
mais dont on ne à mon sens on ne saura
se passer pouvez-vous nous dire ce que
la COP 28 a pu faire avancer sur ce
sujet merci
pour continuons avec une question de
yanniori merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre lors de la COP 28 le
président de la République et son
homologue kazak ont annoncé la tenue du
One water Summit en 2024 en tant que
corapporteur de la mission sur
l'adaptation des politiques de l'eau au
changement climatique je salue cette
initiative l'eau est essentielle pour la
vie et la biodiversité ainsi que pour
toutes les activités humaines
industrielles et agricoles il est
indispensable de protéger la ressource
eau alors qu'elle connaît une crise
majeure et qu'elle vient à manquer ce
sommet diplomatique inédit sera consacré
à l'accès à l'eau pouvez-vous nous en
dire plus sur ce one water Summit quels
sont les enjeux les attentes et le
calendrier prévu notamment sur le lien
entre l'eau et les sujets
énergétiques merci la parole est à
Damien adan merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre j'aimerais ce matin
vous parler du charbon si le charbon ne
représente que 0,6 % du mix énergétique
français en 2022 et si notre pays en
sortira définitivement en 2027 forcé de
constater qu'à l'échelle internationale
c'est un autre sujet en effet 27 % du
mix énergétique mondial est lié au
charbon et la demande mondiale de
charbon bat des records atteignant 8,53
milliards de tonnes cette année selon
agence internationale de l'énergie le
président de la République l'a rappelé
lors de son discours d'ouverture de la
COP 28 500 GW de nouvelle capacités de
charbon sont en cours de planification
les centrales existantes qui se
concentrent largement en Asie
aujourd'hui émettront à ell seul
suffisamment de CO2 pour que nous
excédions la cible de
1,5°gr de l'accord de Paris aujourd'hui
il est temps pour l'humanité de fixer
pour chaque pays une date de fin de
charbon et renoncer à tout nouveau
projet de centrale à ce titre la France
a lancé durant cette COP euh la co
transition accelérator pour mettre en
notre diplomatie au service de l'avancée
vers ce qui est appelé en diplomatie le
call face out pourriez-vous nous parler
plus précisément cette initiative du
nombre de pays qui ont déjà annoncé une
date de sortie de charbon et la manière
dont on va pouvoir aider ces pays à en
sortir aussi merci merci la parole est à
Jean-Luc fuigit merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre je me
réjouis des avancées obtenues à la cop28
qui sont pour moi en lien direct avec
votre action concrète pour notre pays
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai quatre
questions précises à l'occasion de votre
venue récemment dans le rond pour
inaugurer l'usine Symbio de pile à
combustible vous avez présenté les
contours de la future stratégie
nationale hydrogène pouvez-vous
aujourd'hui nous indiquer la place que
cette stratégie fera à l'exploration de
l'hydrogène naturel hier au Conseil
supérieur de l'énergie nous avons
examiné et amendé le décret relatif au
développement de l'agrivoltaïsme mais
pouvez-vous nous préciser votre approche
du développement de cette de
l'agrivoltaïsme en novembre 2022 le
gouvernement a mis en place une
délégation interministérielle au nouveau
nucléaire 1 an après pouvez-vous nous
préciser son apport et son p perimètre
d'action enfin que ce soit pour
accélérer le développement des énergies
renouvelables ou la relance du nucléaire
envisagez-vous un travail spécifique
avec votre collègu de l'enseignement
supérieur pour orienter l'offre de
formation vers les métiers que proposent
ces secteurs merci la parole est à
Stéphane
bchou merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre comme l'ont rappelé un
certain nombre de de collègues cet
accord de la COP 28 prévoit l'abandon
progressif des énergies fossiles et
c'est une avancée et et je je la salue
cet accord est aussi dans le domaine
maritime et et vous le savez l'océan
représente 70 % de la surface du globe
et absorbe environ 1/3 des émissions de
carbone dans le prolongement de de la
question de mon collègue yanncori je
voulais connaître votre sentiment madame
la ministre sur la place de l'océan dans
ces dans cet accord de la COP 28 et
selon vous quel pourrait être ou quels
seront les objectifs toujours en matière
maritime pour la prochaine COP merci
beaucoup merci la parole est à Pascal
Boyer merci monsieur le Président merci
Madame la Ministre ce matin la route
menant à rizou est réouverte cette route
était fermée depuis le 1er décembre le
jour où les pluies diluviennne ont
provoqué de lourds dommages dans le
département des Hautes Alpes les
températures ont atteint des niveaux
record durant l'été 2023 en montagne les
montagnes se réchauffent deux fois plus
vite que les autres écosystèmes la
température y a augmenté de plus de 2°gr
au cours du 20e siècle contre 1,4°gr
dans le reste de la France ces records
de chaleur se traduisent très
concrètement dans nos territoires les
catastrophes naturelles deviennent de
plus en plus gravissimes pour
l'environnement et les activités
humaines madame la ministre n'est-il pas
temps de se préoccuper sérieusement des
conséquences du changement climatique
dans les territoires de montagne au
cours des prochaines COP et dans tous
les autres rencontres qui traitent du
sujet du changement climatique je vous
en remercie merci la parole est à
Emmanuel
maqu merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues madame la ministre à
l'occasion de la COP 28 une vingtaine de
pays dont la France viennent d'appeler à
tripler la production d'énergie
nucléaire d'ici 2030 depuis le lancement
du parc nucléaire français notre pays a
échappé à 25 années d'émissions de CO2
comme celle de 2022 et a évité le
recours à des énergies fossiles comme le
gaz ou le charbon le maintien de notre
production va cependant madame la
ministre requérir un financement
important en faveur du nouveau nucléaire
soutiendrez-vous la demande de DF de
recourir davantage à des contrats de
long terme pour améliorer la visibilité
de ces recettes madame la ministre où en
est où en est-on pardon sur l'énergie
Maré motrice qui présente l'avantage
d'être parfaitement prédictible
n'est-elle pas une perspective
intéressante alors où on cherche de
profiter davantage de l'énergie marine
la géothermie plus particulièrement la
géothermie marine qui exploite les
calories thermiques d'une ressource
inépuissable à savoir la mer est-elle
suffisamment accompagnée dans son
développement merci merci la parole est
àug
Tegna merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre les résultats de la COP 28
constiue une avancée importante dans la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
avec pour la première fois la mention
d'une transition sans les énergies
fossiles or pour atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques l'accélération de la mise en
place d'un modèle circulair au sein de
l'économie circulaire française est
absolument nécessaire le réemploi
l'écoconception et le recyclage ne sont
pas seulement des procédés permettant de
réduire notre consommation en matière
première mais aussi notre empreinte
carbone et si la loi AGC en France a
permis de fixer les des objectifs
nationaux ambitieux en la matière et que
l'Union européenne se sédit du sujet
notamment via le Règlement sur les
batteries du juillet 2023 ou celui des
emballages adoptés par le Parlement
européen le mois dernier une action
coordonnée de promotion de l'économie
circulaire au niveau international est
indispensable madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles sont
les avancées en matière d'économie
circulaire que prévoit la COP 28 et
estimez-vous qu'elles sont suffisantes
au regard de l'urgence des enjux
climatiques je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Jean-Pierre tê
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues madame la ministre madame la
ministre chacune et chacun d'entre nous
a droit au respect dans cette commission
quel que soient ses convictions
politiques je suis surpris par votre
arrogance qui n'a pas rendu service à
votre collègue ministre de l'Intérieur
d'ailleurs nous sommes peut-être des
élus de pacotille mais nous avons la
légitimité du vote ce qui n'est pas
votre cas si je ne m'abuse le texte
final de la COP mentionne le triplement
des capacités d' l'énergie nucléaire
dans le monde d'ici 2050 beaucoup élu
vous exprimer leur scepticisme notamment
lorsque vous avez décidé la fermeture de
fitenheim ils constatent votre lance de
la filière nucléaire après tant de
décision irresponsable pour notre
indépendance énergétique et le
portefeuille des Français à ce sujet les
États-membres et eurodéputés ont conclu
ce jeudi 14 décembre un accord sur une
réforme de marché européen de
l'électricité destiné à favoriser
l'investissement dans les énergies
décarbonées y compris le nucléaire et à
modérer les factures des consommateurs
pouvez-vous nous dire quelles sont les
modalités de mise en place et le
calendri de cet accord en France vous
n'avez pas répondu également à notre
collègue ver Morel sur le calendrier de
la PPE pouvez-vous le faire je vous
remercie madame la ministre merci la
parole est à Vincent deckur merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
l'objectif affiché à l'issue de la COP
28 une transition des énergies fossiles
suppose une évolution en profondeur de
notre mix énergétique et la montée en
puissance de l'électricité plusieurs
collègues viennent d'évoquer
l'indispensable relance de la production
d'énergie nucléaire ma question porte
sur la production d'énergie
hydroélectrique aujourd'hui contrarié
par la question euh restée en suspend de
l'ouverture à la concurrence des
concessions une préoccupation que notre
commission d'enquête sur les raisons de
la perte de notre souveraineté
énergétique avait pointé du doigt
préconisant une évolution du cadre
juridique qui permettrait la reprise des
investissements trop longtemps différés
en particulier sur les ouvrages
exploités par EDF d'où ma question
pouvez-vous nous indiquer si ce ce
dossier a connu une avancée merci merci
la parole est à Vincent thébau oui merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
pour terminer mon propos et la question
que j'ai pas que je vous ai pas posé
tout à l'heure notamment dans l'objectif
de réduction et de décarbonation des
énergies je voudrais vous interroger
particulièrement en lien avec une
mission que nous menons actuellement au
sein de la commission avec notamment mon
collègue Gérard Lossel sur le sujet de
notamment de la géothermie géothermie
profonde et géothermie de surface
aujourd'hui c'est une énergie dont on
parle assez peu représente actuellement
une production de 7 TW en France nous
estimons que nous pouvons aller jusqu'à
100 150 traw ce qui représente une part
importante notamment de production de
chaleur sachant que des pays notamment
l'Allemagne qui a certes une géologie
plus favorable peut envisage
effectivement une potentielle de 600 TWh
vous avez mis en place un plan national
notamment sur la géothermie je sais qu'
a les études qui lancé j'aimerais que
vous en dites quelques mots c'est un
sujet qui est assez peu évoqué je pense
que c'est un géant important de
l'énergie renouvelable dont nous avons
besoin merci
merci la parole est à Nicolas
Thierry merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je je suis député de
la Gironde et j'ai besoin de comprendre
la cohérence qu'il y a entre les
déclarations du gouvernement sur la
sortie des fossiles et le choix
d'accorder à la société vermillon
l'autorisation de nouveau puit de forage
de pétrole sur le Bassin d'Arcachon et à
la test de bûche est-ce que vous
concevez que cette décision provoque une
profonde compréhension est-ce que vous
concevez que ce décalage entre discours
et cette décision en Gironde jette un
trouble sur la crédibilité de vos
engagements enfin pour le dire
simplement on a besoin de comprendre
merci donc de m'éclairer sur cette
décision en Gironde qui vraiment fait
qu'on ne comprend plus rien
merci merci la parole est à
marcelonado merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre mon collègue
Jean-Victor Castro a évoqué la situation
des pays du du Sud mais parmi ces pays
du Sud il y a notamment les micros état
insulaires dont les revendications on
été portées brillamment d'ailleurs par
la Prim ministre de de Barbade miam
motelé pour vous dire êtes-vous vraiment
consciente de la situation des des îles
en général qui est parmi des îles qui
sont régies par la France eu égard à ce
la réalité du changement climatique
puisque les accords sembleent être un
changement culturel mais sans moyen
contraignant alors que le changement cl
nous y sommes déjà s'agissant notamment
des problématiques de trait
côte merci et enfin la parole est à
Jean-Louis
bricou non pourtant vous étiez
inscrit est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions pas d'autres questions madame
la ministre je vous laisse le soin de
répondre alors madame la député
brûlebois sur le CCS l'objectif c'est
bien donc capture carbone et
séquestration
nous avons une stratégie nationale qui a
été annoncée en conseil national de
l'industrie par Roland lescur et
moi-même fin de premier semestre elle
est complétée et précisée dans la
stratégie française énergie climat elle
fera l'objet de soutien financier avec
une double logique on réserve les CCS
aux secteurs qui ont des émissions les
plus difficile à abattre ça ne peut pas
être une solution qui répond à tous les
projets ça doit être limité vraiment
à des usages euh sur lequel on n' pas
d'alternative premer point et deuxème
point on accompagne ou ça peut être des
solutions de transition le le temps de
mettre en place les filières hydrogènes
puisqu'on a C cette situation également
et nous mettons en place les
infrastructures enfin nous envisageons
de mettre en place les infrastructures
et les soutiens financiers pour
permettre à cette carture carbone de se
faire et je signerai avec la Norvège un
accord en la matière puisque la Norvège
est un des pays le pays le plus avancé
en Europe en matière de de de capture et
de séquestration carbon pour permettre
notamment sur le D carerqua de pouvoir
ouvrir des solutions euh sur le One
water Summit monsieur Orry avec le
Kazakhstan l'objectif c'est de faire ce
que nous avons fait avec le One Planet
Summit le One forest Summit le One polar
Summit c'est-à-dire de cristalliser des
coalitions de pays pour avoir des
agendas complets qui permettent de
répondre à des enjeux majeurs d'un point
de vue climatique et sortir du seul
problème de la baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre parce que se
concentrer seulement sur la baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de ser c'est
par c'est passé à partir c'est passé à
côté d'une partie des sujets et en
particulier je pense que tout le monde
partagera ici que l'enjeu de l'eau est
un enjeu géopolitique et existentiel
absolument mal majeur dans euh la le
sujet de de la transition énergétique et
écologique et donc c'est tout l'enjeu de
le faire euh avec le le Kazakhstan à
chaque fois qu'on prend des initiatives
l'objectif c'est aussi de conjuguer euh
pays du Nord pays développés et pays en
développement pour donner de
l'attraction à nos initiatives et on
peut le voir le One forestit et
aujourd'hui suivi des faits euh et c'est
toute l'intention et tout le le poids
que nous voulons nous voulons mettre
dans ce one water Summit sur le charbon
euh monsieur Adam euh la coalition qu'AB
batti le président de la République et
qui l'élargit euh à la faveur de de
cette COP 28 c'est une coalition qui
vise trois choses on a aujourd'hui
asséché les financements publics au
charbon en particulier euh les pays du
G7 c'est un engagement qui avait été
obtenu qui avait été beaucoup poussé par
par la France euh nous voulons assécher
les financements privés au charbon prier
élément 2è élément euh nous voulons
élargir la coalition des pays qui
s'engagent à ne plus ouvrir de nouvelles
centrales à charbon trisème élément euh
nous voulons trouver les modalités
d'accompagnement des pays qui sortent et
qui arrêtent des centrales à charbon
pourquoi parce qu'arrêter une centrale à
charbon on le voit en France dans les
situations de cord deem ou de saintavold
ça veut dire mettre en place
l'accompagnement sociale et la
reconversion économique qui permettent
de le faire et donc pour un pays comme
nous c'est déjà pas si évident que ça et
ça suppose des financements importants
pour des pays qui sont confrontés à des
enjeux de développement et qui ont une
date élevée c'est encore plus compliqué
donc là encore tout le sujet c'est d'
apporter des solutions ne pas juste être
moralisateur disant il y a qu'à
faucon voilà donc c'est c'est une un des
éléments sur lequels le président de la
République c'est s'est engagé monsieur
le député flugit sur l'exploration
d'hydrogène naturel j'ai signé les
premières autorisations d'exploration
tout l'enjeu est effectivement de
mesurer
un de quel volume parle-t-on est-ce que
c'est beaucoup est-ce que c'est peu de
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière cette
exploration c'est-à-dire est-ce que
c'est une exploration qui nous donne
accès à un hydrogène blanc comme on
l'appelle en quantité importante et qui
a un coût compétitif n permet
d'alimenter nos filières industrielles
ce serait une très bonne nouvelle ce
n'est pas une énergie renouvelable par
construction parce qu'on l'extrait de
nos sols mais elle complémente tout ce
qu'on est en train de faire donc ça ce
serait l'option très favorable l'option
défavorable c'est qu'à la faveur des
moyens d'exploration nous contribuons à
sortir du méthane qui est un des gaz les
plus
réchauffant en matière climatique et
donc c'est qu'en fait la balance
technologique ne soit pas bonne
technologique et climatique ne soit pas
bonne à ce stade du développement nous
le savons pas et c'est pour ça que nous
sommes en phase que nous autorisons les
explorations de manière très contrôlée
pour savoir le rapport on va dire coût
avantage de cet hydrogène blanc certains
sont extrêmement positif dessus je
dirais que mon expérience de ministre
m'a appris à pas penser qu'il y a des
martingales qui répondent à tout mais si
ça complémente ce qui existe déjà ça
sera très bon très bien et le président
de la République a très clairement
indiqué son engagement derrière cet
hydrogène blanc le décret Agri
photovoltaïque je sais que c'est un
décret qui soulève beaucoup de questions
notamment par rapport à la question de
la souveraineté agricole je le redis je
me suis engagé et c'est ce qui est écrit
dans la loi donc de toute façon c'est
écrit dans la loi ça prend le pas sur
toute mise en œuvre c'est le juge le
fera respecter le développement de l'AG
voltaïsme ne doit pas impacter les
rendements agricoles c'est théoriquement
le contraire c'est théoriquement le
contraire tout l'enjeu c'est de ça c'est
de le faire de manière ordonnée et
équilibrée c'est ce qu'essaie de faire
ce décret qui ne peut pas aller sur la
question du partage de la valeur parce
que les législateurs le législateur ne
l'a pas permis dans le partage de la
valeur on peut faire une petite
ouverture contenu de ce qui est écrit
mais la question des bails ruraux pour
les former n'est pas traité par la loi
accélération des énergies renouvelables
et donc il y a probablement un espace
qui aujourd'hui est un angle mort de la
loi et qui est à la conflu enfin la à la
rencontre de la question énergétique et
de la question agricole et qui est un
vrai sujet
FCI pour le foncier c'est en gros
comment fait-on pour organiser le
déploiement de l'agrivoltaïsme en ayant
bien en tête que ça doit avoir et vous
l'avez très bien écrit dans la loi je
veux dire la loi elle dit tout à fait
pas question de baisser les rendements
agricoles il doit avoir un bénéfice
agricole et donc de meilleurs rendement
et cetera pour permettre l'agrivoltaïsme
mais nous savons tous que la loi
peut-être interprétée et qu'elle peut
être qu'on peut en avoir un usage qui
permet de la contourner et c'est ça qui
inquiète un certain nombre d'acteurs et
c'est une inquiétude légitime donc nous
on a travaillé très fortement avec les
Chambres d'agriculture pour mettre tous
les encadrements possibles avis conforme
de la CdP NAF ça c'est vous qui l'avez
fait mais effectivement la notion du
bail rural qui est rémunéré quelques
centaines d'euros sur une exploitation
agricole et vous avez des opérateurs qui
arrivent en vous disant c'est formidable
faites des PV un petit peu de mouton en
dessous et ça sera quelques milliers
d'euros par hectare ça pose un problème
d'équilibre et je pense que c'est un
sujet sur lequel nous devons
collectivement travailler euh sur la
délégation NNF donc nouveau nucléaire à
quoi ça sert ça sert à suivre pas à pas
pour le gouvernement en
interministériel la préparation l'état
de préparation de la filière nucléaire
l'état de préparation la montée en
compéten de notre pays avec en lien avec
l'université des métiers du nucléaire
l'état de préparation des procédures
nucléaires et l'accompagnement de tous
les les chantiers euh et c'est donc
cette cette délégation qui nourrit aussi
tous le les travaux entre autres du
Conseil de politique nucléaire avec
l'ensemble des équipes il est également
positionné sur les réacteurs RGH Jul
rovit et sur ce type de réacteur de
recherche qui contribue à renforcer
notre connaissance et notre excellence
nucléaire sur l'offre de formation oui
nous travaillons avec Sylvie enfin oui
je travaille plutôt avec Sylvie
retaillot euh notamment en Normandie
vous savez qu'on a annoncé 40 millions
d'euros de soutien pour accompagner la
filière nucléaire et les formations et
les universités du bac pro jusqu'au bac
+ 5 avec notamment une notion de de de
passeport nucléaire qui consiste à
mettre au bout d'une formation de type
BTS au bac pro des heures
supplémentaires avec qui donnent une
coloration nucléaire à la formation vous
avez donc des chaudroniers nucléaires
vous avez des soudeurs nucléaaires j'ai
5 minutes me dit-on euh madame voyez je
je prends euh j'entends votre inquiétude
sur sur la montagne inquiétude que nous
partageons tous par type de de je DIRIS
de géographie ceux qui sont proches des
côtes s'inquiètent légitimement sur le
trait de côte ceux qui sont en montagne
voient le réchauffement climatique
impacter plus fortement leur territoire
que d'autres et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
agir et c'est pour ça qu'il faut et
développer du renouvelable et développer
du du nucléaire parce que on s'inquiète
parfois de l'impact de ces équipements
sur les paysages mais ce qui est en
traain de
transformer fondamentalement nos
paysages c'est le dérèglement climatique
c'est le dérèglement climatique donc oui
et vous avez raison il faut un fort
volet adaptation pour permettre à ces
territoires de faire face là aussi plus
on anticipera plus on fera les
investissement moins on se retrouvera en
situation de subir l'impact du
dérèglement climatique sur monsieur
maqué le financement du nucléaire je
vous confirme que nous soutenons les
contrats de long terme def pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que ça per permet
de donner la visibilité au financement à
à à EDF deuxièmement parce que ça permet
de donner la visibilité au consommateurs
sur leur prix et donc c'est très
important et à un moment où la cotation
de l'électricité est en train de
converger enfin en tout cas se rapproche
plutôt de 80 € on voit toute la valeur
de mettre des volumes de d'électricité
sur le marché en 26 en 27 en 28 et si
possible en 29 de façon à donner cette
visibilité et à permettre à chacun
d'avoir un accès à de l'électricité pas
cher sur le Maré moteur nous avons nous
soutenons le projet flowat c'est
aujourd'hui soutenu à hauteur de 250 270
€ donc on est encore loin d'un prix c
mais c'est normal c'est le temps du
développement il faut prendre un risque
industriel et oui nous nous nous
regardons le Maré moteur pour sa valeur
propre sur la géothermie marine on a
aujourd'hui quelques situations on a
l'hôpital de La Réunion de mémoire qui
est refroidi réchauffé au à la
géothermie marine
il y a d'autres projets qui sont en
train d'être examinés je dirais qu'on
est à un stade plutôt d'accompagnement
red préindustrialisation
prémassification de la solution avant
qu'elle soit totalement compétitive sur
Oui oui le recyclage et et Madame teniab
donc ces objectifs lorsque vous regardez
la COP 28 vous avez un accord chapeau
mais vous avez des centaines de pages
donc ce sont des éléments il y a eu un
gros travail de fait quand même il faut
le dire aussi de la présidence pour
faire rejoindre les agendas climatiques
et biodiversité et l'ensemble des odd
dans un texte unique avec une sorte de
d'un Jada de travail climatique et
biodiversité dans lequel vos
préoccupations sont
mentionnées monsieur le député
tê si j'ai fait preuve d'arrogance je
m'en excuse mais je mentionne aussi que
je pense que politiquement il est
intéressant de pointer certaines
incohérences dans certains discours et
c'est à ce ce titre et je n'évoque que
des chiffres quand on dit que les
émissions de gaz et effet de serer
augmentent en France alors qu'elle
baisse de 4,6 % c'est un chiffre factuel
quand on dit qu'on soutient les énergies
renouvelables et qu'on ne souhaite pas
voter une loi qui accélère les énergies
renouvelables c'est factuel j'espère que
mon propos n'a pas dépensé cette passé
cette pensée sur electricityé Market
design les modalités de de de mise en
place il y en a pas puisque c'est un
règlement il est d'application direct
donc il y a pas besoin de transposition
sur le calendrier PPE nous avons une loi
de souveraineté énergétique qui doit
être présentée dans les prochaines
semaines vous savez que nous y
travaillons la stratégie française
énergieclimat a été soumise à la
concertation et donc chacun tout à
chacun peut y répondre et le programme
la PPE suit derrière et donc c'est un
enjeu de l'année
2024 ah pardon non c'est deuxème page
sur
l'hydroélectricité
euh pardon monsieur le député des cœur
j'en encore quatre sur
l'hydroélectricité nous travaillons vous
avez je crois auditionné récemment mais
plutôt en commission
d'ailleurs la à côté affaires économique
lucrémont a une approche d'autorisation
elle est en discussion aujourd'hui avec
la Commission européenne donc oui il y a
des avancées mais le scénario n'est pas
final n'est pas ficelé monsieur thébo
sur la géothermie je vais annoncer un
deuxième volet du plan géothermie cette
semaine je suis pas sûr qu'il fasse la
une des journaux puisque d'autres choses
le font mais euh l'enjeu est évidemment
d'accélérer sur la géothermie là les
deux points bloquants c'est clairement
la structuration de la filière
industrielle et c'est les compétences et
notamment les compétences de forage et
donc on met mais voilà il y a une
question de d'accélérer ça de monter en
en taille monsieur Terry euh la sortie
des fossiles c'est nous qui l'avons voté
c'est ce gouvernement enfin pas ce
gouvernement en l'occurrence c'est la le
précédent quinenas mais c'est
sous le quinquena du président Macron
que la sortie des fossiles a été votée
nous ne donnons plus de permis
d'exploration et de production sur les
énergies fossiles et c'est un sacré
prise de de responsabilité puisque comme
le mentionnait votre collègue guyané ça
veut dire que la Guyane se prive se
prive d'avoir accès à cet argent
facilement gagné parce que il y a
peut-être pas beaucoup de pétrole en
métropole mais il y en a dans les
territoires
ultramarins donc je je vous le dis nous
nous respectons la loi par ailleurs vous
parlez d'une décision je ne sais pas de
quelle décision vous parlez je ne sais
pas de quelle décision vous parlez à ce
stade à ce stade il n'y a pas de
décision sur la Gironde voilà et nous
notre enjeu et c'est vous qui avez enfin
cette loi elle a été votée vous la
connaissez mieux que moi c'est une
sortie d'ici 2040 des gisement existant
et d'ici 2040 il faut le faire là aussi
en bon ordre en permettant aux G
questionnaires qui ont signé leur
contrat en 1965 pour les premiers et qui
l'ont renouvelé en 2010
euh de le faire en bon ordre et
notamment de remettre en état pour
remettre en état il faut avoir les
financements qui vont avec en terme de
pollution sur la situation des petites
d'Illes c'est je je je pense que vous
avez raison de mentionner les petits
diles des petites îles comme touvalou
10000 habitants sur 8 milliards
d'habitants de la planète ça pèse peu
mais ces petites îles ont été absolument
instrumentales pour permettre cet accord
ces petites îles elles ont été à la
manœuvre et elles ont permis avec les
Européens de faire cette cette coalition
de 130 pays et d'embarquer les pays
ambieux d'Amérique latine d'embarquer
une partie des pays d'Afrique enfin
parfois en difficulté en dilemme par
rapport à leur enjeu de développement
économique d'embarquer le bangladesch et
les pays les moins les moins développés
et et donc effectivement ils ont eu une
part de voix qui était importante parce
qu'ils sont le leur sujet est une un
sujet existentiel ils ne sont pas
confrontés à l'impact du changement
climatique ils sont confrontés à leur
disparition de leur pays c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinairement violent et
donc oui nous sommes tout à fait en
appui de de ces pays je rappelle que
c'est le président de la République qui
en lien avec les îles bardad a lancé
notamment et soutenu l'agenda de
Bridgestone et qui en a fait aussi ce
forum de Paris pour la planète et les PE
je crois que j'ai répondu à tout merci
madame la ministre